[Music]
good morning
[Music]
dance dance
dance dance
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
by the power of crowder shop
i have the power
dave you're not wearing pants tis true
where'd dave get those cool threads
wouldn't you like to know
it's a mystery but you can start your
treasure hunt at
crowdershop.com
i think you'll be pleasantly surprised
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hmm
wonderful wonderful that's a little
moroccan mint uh green tea no that
sounds like that was a reserve
i'm a fan i'm a fan of the tea
not so much the lifestyle over there and
the movie babble
terrible not a fan that's the only one
really how many moroccan themed films i
don't know babble
they just don't have the tax incentives
uh unlike michigan where uh actually uh
dave landau and third year is from how
are you sir ahoy how about you i'm doing
well you have a show coming november
11th at the cotillion in wichita
yes we found a place that doesn't make
you get vacs oh oh nice i'm going to
wichita
yeah uh last rock band who existed i'm
going to introduce everyone else really
quickly but first look we're going to be
talking there's a new drug coming out
from merck the creators of uh ivermectin
and of course uh 300 some million
dollars from the federal government for
a vaccine look this is something we
always have to be really careful in
discussing on youtube because you can't
necessarily cite peer-reviewed published
studies
if they just don't like them yeah and we
stumbled across some some scary uh
information here that since we've
actually referenced peer-reviewed
medical studies they've since been
removed not because they were inaccurate
but because they didn't like that they
had been referenced as a source so
oh well dang it i'm sorry
and we're going to talk about that and
of course the new wonder drug oh new
wonder drug from merc the red pill yeah
and really quickly look i want to ask as
you can comment below we've always
talked about our line in the
sand we're going to be talking about
fauci saying we can't we can't say
christmas we don't know it's too early
to tell it's never been easier to draw
your line in the sand how are you going
to celebrate christmas with as many
humans as possible in your house that's
all you have to do right now
oh it sounds like a great plan is be
merry and keep chris you know what and
if you keep christmas in your heart all
year round it can be christmas every day
i love it it is tough trying that in
july but
the point remains you can just tell
people religious exemption all right we
have gerald a how are you i am i'm i
might have the covet you might have this
oh yeah i doubt it yeah i got it i mean
i just feel really run down so oh great
oh my gosh i know it's going to give it
to me stop the presses terrible he feels
slightly groggy oh it's got to be
covered
do i have covert or did i take benadryl
in the last 24 hours that's true it is a
similar is it a high pollen day or am i
going to die
better create the quarantine camps which
will be completed in 2024
in australia yeah i'd be on a train if i
was in australia right now heading out
to the sorry
getting three squares of porridge yes
lisa can i have some no you can't have
more all right uh quarterback is here
what's up what's going on i'm ready for
the holidays i'm going to party try it
i'm going to try to party as much as i
can you're going to try and party yes
my relatives in you know avoid if any if
anyone if any membrane comes in with a
scythe you do not let him in the door
uh here's i think a perfect
crystallization it's been trending well
actually it was trending on twitter and
then they switched it yeah
trump of course of course they did uh i
don't know and you guys comment and tell
me what you think was going on brandon
brown i have to make sure i get the name
right because i don't follow nascar
uh there's a nascar for dummies book oh
really yeah is that just nascar yes
kidding guy now it's just chapter one
lost half our fans half our audience is
like ah
i used to work in race yeah you're right
chapter one just turn left chapter two
are you still reading this
keep turning left if you're watching an
instructional on netflix the q would say
are you awake are you still we told you
to turn left
yeah try to go faster than the other
cars yes what's your favorite brand home
depot or lowe's
[Laughter]
they are god loving people and they
support this country well yeah except uh
they are here's the thing the nasdaq
the nascar fans are different from the
nascar organization yeah and this just
it just shows the chasm that exists
between all of these or whether it's we
think it's just hollywood entertainment
industry but they really do have control
over sports with nascar and this wokism
it's look you need to know your audience
yeah and it was very clear that with
bubba wallace it was a garage door
opener did they ever apologize for that
no no no no they didn't the fbi is at
the bottom of it though it also wasn't
the size of a new it was just to put
your hand in like a finger hole
dave what was it a noose for ants yeah
so on saturday brandon brown won his
first ever nascar xfinity race there you
go i like xfinity all right this um
[ __ ] prefers spectrum she's one of them
fruits
uh
and his po his post race interview this
this this uh this dame from nbc sports
they started cheering the f joe biden
and she was saying she thought they were
cheering uh we love brandon i don't know
if she thought that or if it was a
cover-up you guys watch thank you so
much
hair looks like a pixar character thank
you all of our partners
oh my god just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me christopher
lloyd at the end of roger rabbit the
crowd
[Applause]
let's go brandon you told me you were
gonna kind of hang back those two stages
and just watch and learn
listen to him cheer you brandon they
love you
you heard her laugh before she said that
she's like uh so the crowd is really
behind you bro you're chanting let's go
brandon
i mean that what's with the hair it's
like if you can't if he came out like
that like my child like god what were
you just like were you running late like
oh and his hair cotton ball what the
hell's the difference he's ready i heard
a dreadlock for the last hit locks yeah
he's wearing a racing helmet for the
last two and a half hours trying not to
die oh okay well so his hair's not great
oh that's fair i just thought it was a
little tough well he should but she
should put a hat on that's brandon you
can sell that what yeah bro what do you
think before i move on do you think that
she genuinely thought they were saying
let's go brandon oh no no i don't know i
think it was complete coverage she could
be an idiot she's on the street she's on
the course it's loud maybe no it's
she's a track what the hell is going on
here's crap well she's a woman
with sports i i don't
i don't think she knew what she was
talking about yeah they always look
there are some female broadcasters who
are great with sports and there are some
who clearly know nothing about this
right and those are my favorites yes
like megan o'leary with the ufc she's
unbelievable she's one of the best she's
married to a fighter she really knows it
and then you have some people who come
out like so uh um chuck lidl you're like
oh my god please go away it appears he's
hitting him he's hitting him really hard
oh my god that does not look fun is
did they sign up for this do they know
that he would be kicking him in the
teeth
oh there goes his teeth oh what are the
women coming in can you punch in the
tits
which by the way if i were a female
fighter that's all i would do just like
a speed bag
i don't know if it's against the rules
don't care does it even hurt though i
mean that's just like that that's gonna
hurt right a tid punch would hurt yeah
yeah angela i don't have them i don't
know i'm not saying i wouldn't was a man
to a woman i'm saying it was if i were
if i was a woman fighting a woman it's
very easy if you hit to the groin it's
clear that it's illegal right there's no
other reason yeah but you know you could
be punt you could go for the head you go
a little low you could be hitting an
uppercut and just you know knock herself
out any fight i've ever been in oh balls
that's what
you go for
it's a quick easy win straight up the
pipe all right so it's just wrong dave
well go here because this is a trend and
it's been growing it hasn't slowed down
and uh the media obviously doesn't cover
it um some of the most popular posts at
the website lightworkersquad.com have
been just posting these people chanting
this that's great and then finally when
they were caught with their pants i'm
like oh let's go brandon so this started
or we covered on the show i believe was
it september uh 13th it was chanted at
the triller uh fight club event with
donald trump here's the clip when we
first covered it the crowd was seen
chanting and this is not a political
rally this was a fight night right right
this could this could easily be just a
random sampling of the country chanting
we love trump uh followed by a chant
about the most popular president in
history 80 million votes joe biden this
happened organically
special warriors
[Applause]
we're still going strong
[Applause]
that's good that's great
it still makes me yeah it happens at my
show in pittsburgh oh did it again oh my
god it started happening they all were
chanting
f joe biden was it before not in the
middle of your set no is in the middle
of my set either oh no but they meant it
with you know i don't know oh yeah yeah
yeah but i even said i'm like guys this
is a stand-up show it's literally the
worst place you can do this i agree with
the sentiment right and then they all
stopped oh that's but it was like yeah i
totally i get it there's like wait and
they're just like a dancy kid like can i
say i think they should do it on
broadway shows i think every place that
you gather as a group of people this
chant should start maybe in church maybe
that's the only place
the spider-man show going on before he
plummets to his death as the 19th
incarnation
we have another understudy here
you guys remember that all the safety
hazard the spider-man like who'da
thought yeah it lasted three weeks on
broadway because everyone died yes who's
surprised you two sucks we're a far cry
from julie andrews playing peter pan all
right sweet gail never understood why
the ladies played peter pan it was early
social engineering so this has been
going on for a while here's a quick
montage for those of you who missed it
it's been going on this is the trend
it's like uh it's like a planking
only with disdain for the former vice
president of the united
[Applause]
i states it
[Applause]
expect bane to come out with a what a
lovely voice
i agree
the city can be saved
these are not just red states that was
usc a second ago michigan before that u
of m is not
no
ann arbor is not a bastion of
conservatives
just to be clear
that's kind of an event
when it happens in europe so let's let's
go through we have 3.5 trillion dollars
in spending or as they call it a
rounding error that obviously will never
be able to actually pay for even if you
increase taxes on the wealthy despite
the fact that tax revenue went up under
donald trump with tax cuts it's
something called the laffer curve or
herzog's law we've talked about our
households lost or we've talked about it
uh what else we have killed a keystone
uh pipeline right obviously uh
supporting pipelines in foreign
countries uh russia russia those union
workers uh covered vaccine mandates we
have a border crisis which is worse than
it's ever been in modern american
history not to mention the afghanistan
pull-out that uh obviously caused the
death of americans and plenty of our
afghan allies going directly against the
advice of military leaders with no
accountability so this is why you're
seeing people out there i i think
[Music]
[ __ ] joe biden
yes i think that's the sentiment yeah i
think so yeah i think roughly that beep
was spot on yeah that was that was
accurate
gotta love it if it was close all right
i just thought it was great
that made it funnier
i apologize if you have kids in the room
i was that's our intending for the
bleep to work it's all right if kids in
the room have watched it at any football
game they've not yeah
yeah they don't believe it all right or
if they watched any hockey game before
the 2000s where they were being
interviewed by women with a big swinging
dick
they would be interviewed all the
russians all the hockey players i was i
was in the philadelphia flyers locker
room back when it was uh uh eric lindros
rod brendamore joel otto kevin
and uh where are you hiding i i saw eric
lindros's penis wow oh no and i saw his
penis while he was being interviewed by
a lady reporter in the locker room
that's a good thing you don't understand
they're not wearing a towel they're just
standing there look at that can you get
a towel somebody gets the cte remove the
ability for you to just have the
forethought to put on a towel i'm too
old to go diving into a locker i can't i
don't have time to be grabbing towels
i have an interview to do with it lady
who's here lady who's in
hockey is a different sport thank god
there's a camera yeah
[Laughter]
she tossed a woman into a room naked man
good luck
not a good player
we'll send a camera crew and go with you
okay hold on let me take my bullet
points is this hockey today
oh no wow that's uh there's a lot of
these my eyes are up here lady yeah it
just got a little sassy so uh last
night 60 minutes uh a news magazine
program
the best it's different from a news show
is it really the news magazine program
news magazine program i apologize
program
what's his name on right
rooney
andy rooney i have no idea the facebook
whistleblower was uh francis hogan
yesterday uh and this is the new
facebook whistleblower and look i want
to tell you look
people are talking about this now and i
want people out there who not just if
you're conservative if you value your
liberty you know they always say oh
they're they're racist dog whistles
right where people for example things
like freedom things like taxes right
things like don't tread on me they say
these are secretly racist dog whistles
tea party racist dog whistle magazine
racist dog whistle these aren't dog
whistles when we're talking about
supporting authoritarianism so much as
giant loud whistles okay just to be
clear you guys beware the trojan horse
with this lady whenever someone uses the
term hate speech unironically or
whenever someone tries to say that we
need to be doing more about
misinformation while simultaneously we
have twitter fact-checking obituaries
and we'll get to snopes in a second on
the new drug coming from merck these are
not people who are looking to regulate
the industry in a way that is pro
freedom in a way that opens up
competition so a lot of i see people
both on the left and the right thinking
that this is something that it's not um
let's just let's let's look at what she
had to say on 60 minutes francis haugen
told us she was recruited by facebook in
2019 she says she agreed to take the job
only if she could work against
misinformation
like when she had lost a friend to
online conspiracy theories what's lane's
face
drinking tap water shows that it
amplifies hate misinformation and
political unrest he started accusing the
company
for being homosexual
shows that the company is lying to the
public about making significant
hate violence and misinformation hate
violence misinformation information
environment that is full of angry
hateful polarizing content
our civic trust can you turn around so i
can finish it erodes our ability to want
to care for each other
the version of facebook that exists
today
is tearing our societies apart and
causing ethnic violence they
told us we're dissolving civic integrity
like they basically said oh good we made
it through the election there wasn't
riots we can get rid of civic integrity
there were plenty of riots before the
election what are you talking about
black lives matter
and
when they got rid of civic integrity it
was the moment where i was like
i don't trust that they're willing to
actually invest what needs to be
invested to keep facebook from being
dangerous now to keep facebook from
being dangerous be aware of what she's
saying it's dangerous if people are
allowed to spread misinformation with
what's misinformation for example you're
not allowed to discuss ivermectin yeah
that was something they're not allowed
to suggest that uh the sea originally
right when they said there would be two
point whatever million deaths in america
you weren't allowed to suggest that that
would be incorrect when they said that
masks don't work don't wear masks you
were not allowed to say actually that's
not true if used in the appropriate
hospital setting of course now you're
not allowed to say actually masks may
not be as effective if not used in their
appropriate hospital setting with these
certain set of guidelines in those cases
of course masks are appropriate and
masks can work if you follow the
guidelines that we've always had for
masks i've got to be very very careful
very careful otherwise it could be
misinformation i know when you had
people saying it was a mortality rate in
the general population of four percent
you couldn't say actually these doctors
say that it's it is significantly more
comparable to uh let's just say uh less
deadly viruses or diseases than one that
might kill you at four percent getting
into borderline polio territory that's
misinformation let's be really really
clear when she says we want to get
misinformation and i lost a friend to
misinformation and they continually
recite rules like hate speech if anyone
uses the term hate speech this is
someone who believes in an authoritarian
government hate speech is not a thing it
does not exist it is not real it is an
all-encompassing term that allows
someone to determine what is too
offensive to be spoken c australia see
canada where comedians and pastors get
jailed yeah absolutely and people never
ask that second question it's like oh
well it sounds good to get rid of
disinformation and hate sure it's like
okay we'll define it no one nobody can
and two no it will always change because
it is not definable it just depends on
who is making the judgment call at this
and we just talked about somebody on
twitter fact checking an obituary yeah
okay come on guys are you the same
people telling me on facebook that this
is hate speech really yeah this is
what's going on right now in this
country so let's compare that by the way
what was the coverage of uh of the james
o'keefe whistleblower from project
veritas that didn't get a 60-minute
special i wonder if it could be maybe
for uh
can we roll that clip facebook uses
classifiers in their algorithms to
determine certain content to be what
they call vaccine hesitant where they
call it that his mistake is he brought
the user's knowledge they assign a score
to these comments that's called the vh
score
vaccine hesitancy score and based on
that score
we'll demote or leave the comment alone
depending on the content within the
comment what's your read on this the
borderline vaccine framework shocking
stories potentially or actually true
events or facts that can raise safety
concerns and by the way we've run a
follow of this on youtube of course
potentially in the past where they go
even if you quote the cdc but it may
craft uh a narrative that might cause
vaccine hesitancy they reserve the right
to you know it used to be there were
community guidelines and there were
advertiser friendly guidelines then they
created someone industry referred to it
as a crowded rule borderline content
sorry
you screwed it up for everybody way to
go dang it screwed up for everybody by
providing references and sources true
that's the problem is when they can't
get around hold on a second you're
providing references and sources to
pubmed you're providing them to liberal
sites and again all references available
today at louderathcrowder.com we if we
can use new york times or fox news we'll
use the new york times if we can use an
objective resource that's what we use
first and they say well you did use
these sources but it may cause vaccine
hesitancy so uh uh disappear you go
your story doesn't matter and this lady
wants that yes let's be clear she wants
that and as far as i've seen she doesn't
have the same level of receipts and
research as the james o'keefe guy yeah
well and one of the things that facebook
did and by the way i don't know if you
guys thought this but when i saw that
this story was happening i was like oh
good somebody's gonna come out and tell
us how like diabolical facebook is and
like how in the bag for democrats and
liberals they are and how much they want
a silent speech they disagree with
whoops i have no idea that that was
coming out out of the gate like oh it
needs to be more like you need to
suppress i was tipped off when i first
saw the the numbers 60.
i knew where it was going you knew
before i did but one thing that they'll
do they'll just like they did for i
can't remember what live stream it was
maybe it was the oscars well they just
pulled it down always yeah remember oh
yeah yeah yeah long time ago so that's
what well the stephen colbert thing we
did last week just got blocked and right
countries specifically japan first and
we've seen in the past where they block
it in the country with heavier copyright
laws and then it moves to another
country and then effect eventually it's
blocking the united states the manual
review to be clear we were clearly
reacting to the god-awful dress up as
vaccines and dance like a san francisco
pride parade they had needles dancing
and we're the ones that are right
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in late nights yes there's
nothing worse it's worse than the heart
attacks that took place on air it's
worse than james whatever his name is
doing carpool karaoke uh well let's not
get ahead of herself all right you're
right that's pretty bad yeah exactly i
hope he never gets t-boned that's caused
un
i just hope he never plays carpool
karaoke with caitlyn jenner no ever
ever i was at the uh i was actually at a
chill at a store we'll just say cause i
don't know if we're allowed to legally
say children's literature section
yeah or you're at the airport oh you
could call it the airport okay sure
i was in an airport bathroom and then i
went over to this place with sorry uh
but yeah i went uh it was a children's
literature literature section at the
airport which i don't know if you've
been to the airport and seen the
literary stuff but there's a book uh
mediocre about uh white men uh every
single book is about how i'm terrible
yeah i'm like do i read white fragility
yeah or just i should die by dl hugley
you know it's it's
a little too on the nose dave landau
sucks yeah like wow crazy very
specifically like it's written by these
algorithms really customizing this yeah
but yeah this is what i saw yeah we saw
you look at that three books in a row
about [ __ ] yes
people are listening on audio like why
does it say
well what's the new butt what's that
yeah that's a real one yeah no i know
well the the the prequel was um uh oscar
visits the folsom street fair yes
yeah the sequel to the fouchy one will
be how the fauci became a doctor and
stole christmas yes
yeah not even an ivermectin too small
for a mouse
just tapping it out of their fingers
his heart grew three sizes that day
because of uh a coveted disease
that is not proven to be a side effect
i was exacerbated three times that day
he's not seen a patient in several years
sled just goes over the dog like well
you know listen okay what do you think's
going to happen with a cardiac arrest
i'm i i'm i am terrified though that
there are fouchy dolls and books though
in every children's section yeah it
really is a little weird and we're going
to get to fouchy saying you can't
celebrate christmas this is the this is
a man more drunk on power than anyone
i've ever seen i know people say donald
trump not even close and what's worse is
this is a man who was unelected and is
one of the highest paid officials in all
of government accountable to no one he's
been right almost never when you go
throughout when you go back to aids go
and see what you're saying about age go
look up our segment vouch you with aids
you probably have to go to the website
because youtube won't show it to you
said kids could get it from a cereal box
if they lived in a house that it could
be airborne right this guy was wrong
about a lot and he is drunk with power
but first before we go to that look i
want to be clear too i'm not a fan of uh
senator cinema
a lot of people say oh she's moderate
i don't care but i understand that she's
taking a lot of flack from progressives
she's um
she represents her her constituents in
arizona and there was a video here where
people followed her uh i think this
girl's name blanca blanca blanca
followed her uh into the bathroom
because of this bill right the
infrastructure bill and is complaining
about uh her not doing enough for
illegal immigrants
and then there's some stuff that you
should know again this goes back to big
tech the fact that this video at the
time of this recording and you guys can
comment below so we kind of keep a
timeline going if it's still up uh at
the time of this recording this video is
still up this girl follows her into the
bathroom to harass her
we need a build back better plan right
now
we're not going to have this
we need solutions and to build that
better plan
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us
we need the
benefit right now
i was brought here to the united states
when i was three years old
and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sc 1070.
and i'm here because oh that
my grandfather passed away two weeks ago
and i was not able to go to mexico and
visit him because there is no pathway to
citizenship and if we have the
opportunity to pass it right now then we
need to do it because there's millions
of undocumented people just like me who
share the same story or even worse just
like you pop into them
and because of anti-immigrant
legislation and this is opportunity to
pass it right now she still has to clean
the bathroom
what you promised us that you were going
to pass when we knocked on doors for you
it's not right
yeah there's a lot that's not right with
this sweetheart and uh poor thing and a
couple of things i might i can't go to
mexico because i'll get stuck really
what's wrong with that huh yeah what do
you mean stuck in mexico what do you do
you mean to say that mexico is an
inferior country to the united states
and that's why you couldn't go because
you wouldn't want to be forced to stay
there because the united states is
better no well then you know what go
back no uh you can't have your cake and
eat it too especially not uh next to a
urinal nope that's interesting i wish
mexico did translate but it kind of does
have your opinion about it break it too
you cannot
this is i just wanted to make it no it's
just it really is difficult though that
when people make the argument that well
hold on a second the united states is
not superior to other countries but it's
a human right
for everyone to come here because it is
uh
uh well not better no just more people
want to come into this country than any
other country in the world for whatever
reason
i love how she said we need the build
back better now and i'm like you didn't
read that that's a 10-year plan did you
yeah you didn't react that's going to
take a while to kick you out what
happened now
oh yeah did you know a politician said
that because that it's not gonna happen
yeah i don't know if you're used to this
yet
they say all this stuff so you vote for
them and then it doesn't happen
for years by the way yeah let me be
clear about this too i watch this as
someone who has recorded a lot of videos
uh regardless of whether a state is a
single-party consent state which means
you can film someone without them giving
you consent it is illegal still to film
someone in a bathroom it is why because
the law says there's a reasonable
expectation of privacy yes when you're
taking a [ __ ] so unlike if you're
publicly protesting at a park like we've
had people who are public protesters and
they go to youtube and say hey i don't
want to be on camera even though i'm in
a public park at a public protest and
youtube says okay we'll remove it or we
have to blur the content this happens
all the time even though we are well
within our rights we've had it happen on
twitter look at project veritas again on
twitter they had their account suspended
for violations of privacy this is a
clear breaking of the law following
someone into the bathroom recording a
video still up
she should have just said i would get
out of here though because speaking of
mexican i had it for lunch yes and this
is about it
you're gross cinema
that's disgusting that is very loud and
splashy that's disgusting
you need to go to an internist
you should be bit by a snake yeah
gluten-free or something i don't know i
don't have a
i don't have papers but i hear it's
better if you like don't eat wheat
[Laughter]
all right like look at this
everyone knows a story well who watches
so when i had bernie sanders on an
airplane yes he was right in front of me
this happened now this happened he was
right in front of me and he had the
economy plus plus plus plus seat right
first class in every single facet except
name and he didn't get a cocktail and uh
he's sitting there with his brand new
ipad i could tell because it had the the
is it the bevel bezel whatever they call
it yeah yeah
i remember i texted you guys you're like
you have you have to go talk to them so
i put on my of course now banned shirt
about socialism uh socialism and uh you
know the stone fruit yeah fruit and uh i
don't know if it's a stone fruit i think
it does because it has a pit what uh
qualifying and then i saw him get off
the airplane it was two in the morning i
went to burlington vermont and he wa
everyone walked one way and he peeled
off and he was walking like brooks from
shawshanks and he just looked so lonely
i said this this isn't fair and i really
hate the so i didn't do it i would have
been well within my legal rights to do
it i don't like doing that you certainly
come on you certainly shouldn't be
following a woman into the bathroom not
to mention it's illegal but this is
again you have these big tech uh really
these oligarchs right you have a few
companies you have facebook you have
amazon you have uh of course youtube
alphabet google
you have twitter you have apple
and they create their own rules that are
separate from the law so in other words
we follow the law we'll get consent for
people to be interviewed
it will be presented to these big tech
platforms and then someone says i don't
care about the law i just don't like uh
being for example and change my mind
they say okay we'll remove it that is
not operating within the law but then
they actually flagrantly disregard the
law so they enforce laws that are not
enforceable by law and then they don't
enforce actual laws at what point do we
say
these are lawless bureaucrats
technocrats who control far too much
information and privacy in our lives if
they're going to be consistent and if
you're going to enjoy the legal
protections of a platform enforce the
law and don't make up new arbitrary ones
instead we have the opposite yeah that
would be the easy way to go right just
enforce it now i don't want to say too
much about this because they could get
mad at us to be like well steven crowder
showed it on his show and so therefore
we have to you know take that down yes
they told us the law that's what will
happen we'll have it taken down of
course but it'll be out there for
everybody to grab from everybody else's
channel like colbert with his needle
sketch uh by the way you can follow us
on instagram uh and on tick tock uh not
uh conceding that territory to those
chad comes even though they remember our
old profile and the best way to tune in
is it's a monday it's a monday through
thursday show live 10 a.m eastern okay
hit the notification bell but just tune
in live that's why we do it because
sometimes subscriptions don't work
in and watch with us and uh we'll be
taking your chats on mug club newest
gender pronouns
before we move on to fouchy and this
medication
uh eminem you found this one dave i did
yes in your hometown the hometown of
detroit homie town the d
the dirty d eminem opened up a
restaurant called mom spaghetti this is
great
vomit on your sweater already yeah
that's a great entry so appetizing he's
italian yeah i don't i don't know
i don't know what he is but i don't know
either way if he says the n-word
someone's getting slapped yeah ask his
dad who introduced himself two years ago
right
like a lottery winner so mom spaghetti
uh and a bunch of uh detroit hipsters
wait in line for hours to eat subpar
pasta and get their albums autographed
by a man who now campaigns for biden uh
here is the ad in detroit for m m's this
is not a joke mom spaghetti
get your sweaters ready detroit
mom spaghetti is coming to 2131 woodward
avenue want some road pasta after the
game got that
meatballs you know we got that what
about the sketti sandwich mom's got that
too get ready to get some mom's
spaghetti detroit opening in the alley
next to union assembly this september
313-888-8388
mom spaghetti it's all ready
ready ready ready
[Music]
wonderful and that brings us to this
week's seven plus one
[Music]
and after that we'll talk there's some
yelp reviews which we'll talk about over
mom's spaghetti
uh
spoiler alert they're not positive not
positive at all so
um this is actually a trend i don't know
this is hip-hop artists you know they're
entrepreneurs did you know this i mean
jay-z is the first black uh billionaire
spell it or whatever him or dr dre
uh i think you when he was jason i don't
know it was like an arms race of crappy
products
200 for headphones they're not even
noise canceling and you'll like it [ __ ]
i guess oh okay but somebody might shoot
you to take them that's how nice they
are like starter jackets back in the day
yeah or like when someone takes their
pimp my ride back to uh southern detroit
southeast detroit oh it's hilarious
my ride he gets there and then
immediately immediately carjacked they
should have a show called unpimp my ride
yeah they just take everything yeah it's
just a follow-up show
called the street pimp my ventilator
um yeah dodge omni doesn't need four
televisions in it
[Laughter]
one of the fords they don't need they
don't need an oxygen bar you never know
like yo i got an oxygen bar in here and
a shark tank oh [ __ ] he's dead well you
know the point remains yeah but look at
it spins yeah am i supposed to feed
these fish
i gotta keep that up you know it's more
it's more of a guideline
so we do we have the top seven hip hop
food franchise oh okay uh dave you
actually have this number seven you're a
fan oh big fan uh we got salt and
peppers mighty muddy good ham oh yeah
that's right that is that is good it's
on brand for them and it's delicious it
is delicious
number six one of my favorites of course
and this seems self-explanatory they
were more piggybacking uh wu-tang
chicken
yeah
with uh the famous tangy rucka sauce
the requests that they bring
the rice sauce
yeah you're gonna get an empty bag if
you don't yeah you're gonna get an empty
bag if you don't get it uh and some old
dirty bastards just gonna slap you
number five is uh sir mix-a-lots baby
got back ribs yeah that's uh that's
self-explanatory i mean that works yeah
it does it absolutely works
uh do you wanna give us number four here
dave you're a fan oh i'm a huge fan i
gotta go flavor flavors of flavor eight
that one's a good one yeah yeah and he's
franchising it's really just a nice it's
really just a a
lemonade lemonade stand but i mean it's
it's flavor flav so for him that's good
is this your own house brand no this
flat this flavor egg is from trader
joe's
yeah i peed in it like problem childs
yeah
like the good son where you have
macaulay culkin haggin elijah wood off
the balcony mr freeway
[Laughter]
number three uh again these are hip-hop
uh food franchises nwa's fudge the
police which was which was miss uh it
was uh misinterpreted there in san
francisco it was yes
it's an ice cream parlor they also sell
kevlar piercing bullets so some could
argue it's a front
yeah some you could yeah uh number two
uh gerald you know you number two from
yeah yeah it's a drake's pancakes that's
right and you were saying dave about
this it's uh well it's good for a
canadian place but uh people pretend
it's way better than it actually yeah it
is oh yeah yeah yeah does he make him
from the wheelchair or right yeah yeah
yeah
grassy yeah
it was a matter of fact i think they
still own the licensing rights
oh well i'm pretty sure yeah the all the
money just goes to degrassi uh number
one cardi b's yeast injection
it's a bakery
what oh i'm sorry i just okay
what's up oh bakery come on i get what
you're saying of course the seven plus
one uh the plus one uh most successful
hip-hop mogul food franchise is lizzo's
all she can eat buffet you get nothing
she just shows up and you sit and you
watch yes that's true you just have an
ipad and watch your instagram that's
been this week seven plus one
[Music]
can i take this off yeah i've never seen
somebody eat for three i don't even
think anyone could see this uh i could
this do rag i could
i brought my own chain the nose plates
it's so much work to look so stupid
you mean awesome what'd you say what
what then we have to i'm standing in my
wrong [ __ ] about forgiveness twist his
cap back rent forgiveness well you spent
twelve thousand dollars on a grill and
four thousand on a back piece that no
one can read
or see most of the time by the way
do you walk around shirtless no well
yeah these are great items to have they
look for reasons i'm a semi-nudist yeah
i am subconsciously dave a mid-drift is
not being semi-nudist he's just a self
he's just a self-conscious nudist
babysitter yeah it's a little bit okay
i wear just a jock strap
yeah yeah that's what i used to do in
the locker room after the hockey games
uh fauci
now this is something he was just
interviewed about this yesterday i
believe
in case you thought the goal posts
hadn't moved enough
now he's this is what look your civil
protest is enjoying your holiday
christmas and of course you know if
they're talking about christmas right
now they're going to do the same thing
with thanksgiving they did it last year
have a merry christmas and a happy new
year who knew that dickens was going to
be the anarchist cookbook
just take some photos and post them
here's fauci saying it may be too soon
to tell if we can celebrate christmas
but we can gather for christmas or it's
just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we just got to concentrating on
continuing to get those numbers down and
not try to jump ahead by weeks or months
okay
so here's something that people need to
take into what's the number we've never
heard that what's the number they mocked
rand paul for talking about herd
immunity then thought she said 70
percent for her immunity as far as how
many people need to be vaccinated then
it went to 75 80. we need to get the
numbers down the numbers are down yeah
the numbers are down dramatically i'll
have them for you so i need to know okay
fauci
come on to a show show that gets
significantly more numbers and whatever
you're doing there on sunday and you can
talk to people convince them change
their minds give them a number people
don't trust you because what you've said
has been factually incorrect you've also
twisted information and you haven't
given specifics for these broad sweeping
generalizations that of course result in
a net loss of more and more freedoms we
need to focus on getting the numbers
down okay let me give you a couple of
numbers um we have a trend of course in
hospitalizations with kovitz since their
peaks at the beginning of august
oh i guess the towards the end of august
beginning of september florida dropped
65 percent okay sixteen thousand five
texas dropped 40 percent hawaii dropped
62 percent georgia dropped 41 percent
also we've seen uh seven day moving uh
the average death rate which is the
number that they use those have gone
down down louisiana down 53 mississippi
down 59 florida down 95 percent what's
the number fouchy yeah did uh did
florida make any major changes by the
way when those numbers started to go up
did texas reinstitute lockdowns and make
sure that everybody had masks in every
possible setting including being outside
in the forest by yourself right sure a
tree fell and made noise no i don't i
didn't see that but their numbers went
down dramatically hawaii did well
they're still releasing attack ads
florida is a great example because
they're still releasing attack ads
against florida yeah right you have you
have the deaths have gone down seven day
average 95
and their cases
65 sorry their their hospitalizations 65
lower and their seven day rolling death
95 percent lower okay so 95 reduction in
deaths that's not what's the number
fauci when do you praise something as a
success now we know early on you praise
new york as a success you praise
michigan as success even though they had
horrible numbers which again goes to
tell you that this isn't a man who is
following numbers data science something
else really concerning we've talked
about australia
why is fauci
why has no one in this administration
expressed concern over australia you're
talking about people who expressed
concern that the taliban's cabinet
wasn't diverse enough so they are not
beyond
intervening
regardless of cultural standards why
have none of our leaders said oh look of
course look you're talking about
quarantine camps that are going to be
built in australia through 2024 that is
not us we will not institute a national
mandate on everybody we are not going to
lock you down and have a curfew no one
has spoken out against women being
chokeslamped for walking their dog after
curfew
and yet they'll be people that say you
have to follow the science in every
single setting right we just i i think
that's scientific florida pretty much
did what a five-year-old does when they
don't want to do something they held
their breath and sat on their hands
right and their cases are down 65 for
hospitalizations 95 for death rate is
that is that i'm just i'm just making
sure because that almost seems like you
have a comparison between hawaii who
locked everybody down again and florida
and texas who did nothing or you have
new york and the results were either
similar or texas and florida
outperformed hawaii yeah i saw the best
tweet it was just that fauci doesn't
want christmas because he doesn't want
to go back to the north pole and make
toys
i laugh for five minutes i'm going to be
a dentist
need voucher chewing dolls
no one wants to play with a fouchy in
the box
oh so i i just hope nobody who's into
voodoo buys one of those and has some
pins yeah me too i hope he doesn't end
up on the island of misfit toys no boy
santa was basically hitler there ufo
you're in perfect your handicap you go
on this island and we'll never see you
again but here's why they haven't spoken
out
against australia listen to fouchy first
off we have another clip or secondly
we'll have a clip of him what he said
about people who are vaccinated she's
now again gone against completely and
what matters is that people followed his
advice
uh but also talking about
your rights or your perceived rights
this is a man who says the quiet part
out loud with total disregard for your
rights this was uh only a couple of days
ago
indeed you do have personal
liberties for yourself and you should be
in control of that well good but you are
a member of society oh no and as a
member of society
reaping all the benefits of being a
member of society you have a
responsibility oh boy to society here it
comes no and i think each of us
particularly in the context
of a pandemic that's killing
millions of people
you have got to look at it and say there
comes a time
when you do have to give up no what you
consider your individual right of making
your own decision
society that if you are vaccinated you
have a very high degree of protection
and therefore you do not need to wear a
mask by the way if i say that right now
we get banned right now wherever you're
watching this we get banned which is why
we have a mirror channel on uh rumble
and of course you can watch the extra
sean mcclellan you know he says what you
perceive what you believe are your
liberties hey hey
how would you define our liberties fauci
shouldn't that be a part of what you
take into consideration here how would
you he's never discussed that yeah i
only follow the science okay 95 lower
deaths 65 lower uh hospitalizations in
florida
you're saying millions are dying well
not in florida and again this is a
regional issue this is a state to state
issue isn't it wonderful don't you
understand federalism but when you say
what people perceive as their rights
fouchy okay since you're the one who is
defining rights define them what do i
have my own pr where does my bodily
autonomy end and your misinformation for
example like on aids begin
he's never called them out on that no
absolutely not and by the way i don't
see him calling people who eat too much
to the mat on that as well saying oh my
gosh you're overrunning our hospitals
with heart disease if he does that he
can't make a guest up on the view well
that's true right and and going after
people who maybe eat too much salt or
going after people who eat too much
sugar drink too many
i know now we gotta throw it away yeah
now we're just gonna try to listen if i
could help you you finally have to get
rid of your own individuality right
think about it as a collective wait a
minute i'm starting to sound like i
don't know every regime in the world
that's killed millions and millions of
people for the good of the collective do
you think anyone or at least pretended
right well but here's the difference at
least they pretended yeah at least they
pretended foundation's like well you
know you think you think you have rights
i don't does anyone say like fouchy stop
stay stop saying stupid [ __ ] yeah okay
don't let on don't say what you perceive
as your just say it's the we would just
go let's follow the science and then
we'll get rid of anyone who disagrees
with you look it makes our job easy
don't say it's time to give up your
liberties
who doesn't want to follow the science
and have a cured disease and the other
part is if we let go of one right that's
just a slippery slope oh my gosh no one
seems to understand that look behind you
you never get all your rights
exactly and by the way the only reason
he said millions of people is because he
wanted to scare you yes millions of
people are dying from this in the united
states millions of people are dying from
this well no not in the united states
well what about texas i don't have a
topographical map or a globe yeah that
would be helpful gotcha journalism much
what about my age group what about what
about my health status huh any of these
things matter i thought this was how
science worked you kind of nailed it
down to the specific person who talks to
their doctor and figures out the best
path forward but millions of people are
dying fauci really yeah look can you
quote that guess what would happen if i
said on the flip side and i'm not saying
this if i said you know covet has killed
uh
hundreds of people boom banned gone
killing millions of people in front of
the night nothing no no accountability
one of the highest paid officials in the
united states government and you didn't
elect him
that's a scary thought okay let's move
on here while we're talking about this
uh
there's a new covent treatment oh good
that uh is coming to market so happy
treatment
we don't ever talk about is that is that
also like therapeutic
is that
is it holistic perhaps i hope perhaps
okay i don't know if i'm allowed to say
but hold on hold on there's none because
otherwise you couldn't get an emergency
approval from the fda so oh i do i think
i just said i think there's something
about that in the regulations near the
back
careful guys misinformation oh
misinformation
so no i'll i'll read from here so merck
i'll read it from ap news because that's
okay that's safe they just announced the
new covenanting pill uh uh monu piravir
i think mona pyramids
it's really close yeah uh
that reduces hospitalizations and deaths
by half wow now i don't think now first
off let me just say if that's true okay
great pfizer also announced an antiviral
treatment uh called df07321232
ask your doctor about pf07321332
no i said 333 i always make a son of a
[ __ ] now you oh no you said three three
now you have the pill that kills you
r-e-s-p-e-c-d five two oh five four
three three
hey there you go give it to me give it
to me give it to mrs guys
these commercials are just awful
my favorite oh oh oh
rocket 10. have you seen that one rock
rocket i guess it's not a commercial
rocket
you know i'm gonna betty i wanna wrench
it you know whatever it is just like
this is so lazy and fouchy's like oh i
love the ozantic commercial it's great
it's a great big fan i love all the hiv
pill commercials it's like
i see a theme i see a theme yeah and
that's that hiv
is uh don't don't don't share the
cinnamon toast crunch with your parents
yeah a lot of dudes in that commercial
that's just that's not it's
just watching the commercial doing very
manly things but the good thing about
this new pill and let me be clear i
would have no problem with a new pill
yeah if it's done on an honest playing
field where we have clinical data where
we not only do have clinical data on all
the available treatments as opposed to
suppression
i would also be fine with it again if we
allow an open market and just like with
other afflictions doctors are allowed to
prescribe off-label this happens
all the time
for example i would be fine with this
alternative treatment if they also
acknowledged some study if they also
started stop talking about a drug that
received the nobel prize for hu in human
use
to which they referred as horse dewormer
on top of everything else the fda has to
warn people not to take livestock
dewormer doctors say oklahomans are
using the cowd warming medicine
ivormectin to treat or prevent cova 19.
for those who may not know the main
ingredient of horse warmer is ivermectin
ivermectin has gotten a lot of attention
lately as people actually push some just
means
protection and treatment i mean other
than just getting the covert vaccine so
things are clearly bad but they're being
made even worse by people who have
refused to take the vaccine and instead
are swallowing horse pace what would you
tell someone uh who is considering
taking that drug
don't do it there's no evidence
whatsoever that that works and it could
potentially have toxicity interestingly
if he says that because we're going to
get into the sciences people who have
gone to poison control centers because
they've taken the drug at a ridiculous
dose and wind up that's that's fact
poison control centers to be clear there
was not an increase in admittance in
poison control centers people were
calling poison control centers asking
can i take this horse dewormer and they
would say no i said all right click but
this idea that these poison control
centers were over burned because people
think horse pace that's not true where's
the fact check on fauci where's the
little disclaimer underneath it you know
like you put up for a woman's obituary
so this is something could this be
when we're talking about this the new
merck drug yeah and keep in mind merck
came out they created ivermectin they
also said was fantastic ivermectin does
not uh work for uh kova they referred to
it as horsty warmer their own medication
yeah uh they received over 300 something
million dollars for uh vaccine from the
federal government nice and of course
they're seeking out a new patent for
this new drug and keep in mind the
reason the new drug the course of a
treatment will be seven hundred dollars
i haven't met you know a handful of
bucks
it's seven hundred dollars for one
course is that's what they're saying
tentatively right now wow which isn't
nearly as bad as some other drugs i
guess i don't know uh but they also want
to get their heart medication uh
approved uh
to be paid for by medicaid so that
should yeah i don't know i'm just
wondering where all the folks who used
to [ __ ] about big pharma went to
could this be oh they're championing
them that's what happens they're
dressing up as them they switch
yeah they're doing entire sketches the
beginning of their terrible talk shows
about it yes it's just propaganda at
this point now let me explain this and
i'm going to get a little nerdy so i'm
going to try to avoid getting off into
the weeds here could it be that they act
ivermectin and this new drug molnu
pyravir i think is how it's pronounced
still good yeah they both function
as protease inhibitors that's a main
mechanism of action now before before
before before you guys get mad i'm going
to go through the science here because i
want to go through some claims that have
been made this is a claim for example
the fat check from snopes trusted when
it comes to fact checking on youtube
they use snopes they use the southern
poverty law center yeah authoritative
good people uh and the patent by the way
expired on ivermectin in 1996. um so
this is from snopes where they say the
claim
is fight pfizer mectin is pfizer's new
drug just ivermectin in disguise
false
okay uh and they say they're not
okay okay i said it on the show i said
fiverr mektin which is funny and they're
they're what they're fact checking let
me bring this up for you
is
the above displayed tweet claims that
pfizer's new drug is simply ivermectin
with a new name that's not true
pfizermectin that's not the claim that's
a joke
then they go on and hear it snopes
you have to go to when you print it out
two pages in okay it says a more nuanced
version of this pfizermecton rumor
claims that both pfizer's new drug and
ivan ivermectin act as potent protease
inhibitors which according to social
media users okay look that's not the
nuanced version that's the version
that's what people are saying and phizer
mechtin is a joke that's funnier than
fiber mechtin i'm kind of upset i didn't
think about it
and you just fact check the onion again
right and they are saying that these
drugs are not protease inhibitors well
look let me read this for you uh it says
currently known as pf07 is a protease
inhibitor designed to block the activity
of the main protease enzyme that is that
the chronovirus needs to replicate this
drug is not a repackaged version of
ivermectin okay let's just be clear it's
true that some of these new drugs act as
protease neighbors let me explain to you
what this means you have to say that
yeah
by the way it shouldn't even come up if
it's not it's like fat check is it
actually called pfizermectin no fact
check do they have a similar mechanism
of action which may explain why oh well
that's more nuanced and let me give you
a non-answer no no no no
can you not address the joke address the
statement yeah i feel like i'm i'm this
i'm this thing like walking around right
now i promise i'm not gerald morgan i
know i put on a jersey that that doesn't
cover up joel morgan very well but i'm
i'm not yeah i am i am now dennis rodman
no now let me be let me clear up some
confusion
some people are now not all these drugs
are just protest inhibitors and here's
what you need to understand okay uh
protease inhibitor what does that mean
it's basically something that the
the short end of it of it is it blocks
replication of the virus in your body
right you have these long chain proteins
you have this binding affiliate affinity
docking affinity that blocks this
replication of the virus but let's just
explain it we have all of the published
research available on the website uh
it's about stopping virus replication in
the body through disrupting its
mechanism of action okay
now
ivermectin was not created as a protease
inhibitor correct a drug like remdezavir
was okay it's often used for virus like
hiv okay now there have been actually uh
some research looking at repurposed
drugs like ivermectin and rem deserve
here's what's interesting the claim is
saying actually avermectin is an
anti-parasitic however
when they compare drugs for protease
inhibition because they were looking to
see what's most effective with covid
since they thought that would work
ivermectin blew them away
blew them away
wow
um as a matter of fact even remdezavir
was blown away okay so there's something
called the moldoc score you don't need
to know what this means necessarily you
can go and look it up after but the
moldoc score takes into account the
totality of how effective it is at
blocking virus replication
ivermectin was 140. remdezavir an actual
protease inhibitor was 111 and then you
have hydroxychloroquine was 88 and uh
fave pi revere sounds like something i
ordered at the lebanese restaurant uh
was 59 which is an actual protein so the
higher the better the higher the better
oh and ivermectin was by far and away
the highest when compared to drugs that
were developed as protease and emitters
let's be really clear about something
here there are drugs that are repurposed
all the time okay for example remember
how they were stabbing hillary clinton
with a diazepam pen like russell crowe
and 310 to yuma do you know what the
answer is it's valium oh and it's
valuable and valium is then used as an
anti-seizure medication there are other
anti-seizure medications but valium was
more effective for specific types of
seizures in some instances my point is
drugs are developed uh in one way and
then they're often discovered to be more
effective sometimes in other drugs
it with a different mechanism that's
what was seen with ivermectin that is
peer reviewed that is published okay
yeah like valium yeah and there's
there's really gonna be seen for fun
yeah it could just be excuse you used
for i call it friday night you want to
have a prescription
but you also need an upper you don't
want to just pass out right you got to
cut it kids yes
little fentanyl goes
don't lose your [ __ ]
tiny pinhead just a
dude so um the new merc drugs this is a
to
dabble
claim that they're making the new merch
drug is an uh antiviral ivermectin is
anti-piracy
okay
that is true but there can be overlap in
use and primarily again the use that
we're talking about here is this moldox
score which largely looks at the
protease inhibition ivormectin is more
effective now here's what's here's
what's really concerning to me and you
just have to uh kind of follow me on
this here is when you look at the new
pill the new merc pill yeah
they were saying okay we're gonna test
it's probably uh a protease inhibition
yeah they compared it
to redesign why
why here's what you usually do with
drugs you compare it to the currently
most effective option that's why when
potheads say it helps by glaucoma and
you say first off you're 22. second
maybe it helps but there are more
effective glaucoma medications out there
which is what why marijuana is not
typically recommended for glaucoma or
cataracts right it's about measuring
against the most effective
version of that medicine out there they
didn't test it against ivermectin they
tested this new drug against rem
desevere which was already blown out of
the water by ivermecton on the moldox
core peer-reviewed medical research why
here's something else when you're
looking at these trials right now the
government has this is overlay l already
has an order uh for 1.7 million courses
so
1.2
billion dollars
for this pill they've conducted clinical
trials and merck hey take a guess how
many clinical trials have they conducted
on their drug ivermectin on which the
patent has expired in 1996
none
less than one none so when you look at
it in vitro study that shows its binding
efficacy
usually that would lead to oh let's now
study it in a clinical trial to see how
effective it is because it was clearly
the most effective at this first stage
of no instead they said let's take the
second most effective which is basically
less effective it's significantly less
effective like almost a third less
effective and let's compare our new drug
to that because well i don't know why i
mean one could say it's difficult to
invest in a clinical trial for a drug
that could be you know printed out very
cheaply yeah well a couple of bucks for
the course of treatment there and look
we wouldn't even really have to ask
these questions if we didn't think that
something fishy was already going on
with the drug companies and i'm being
nice there because they're making
billions of dollars off of
you and you and you and me every one of
us because the government is paying for
all of this stuff and it just come back
to taxes that they're talking about we
have to keep you know raise three and a
half trillion dollars is equal to zero
dollars but nonetheless they are pushing
for something that almost it feels like
this and if somebody makes this claim i
would understand why
it's like ivermectin with like a little
dose of caffeine or something like that
like oh we've changed it just just a
little bit right and then we're
repacking it again like just strip this
jersey off put this jersey on it and
throw it out there the only reason we're
saying that is because you guys have
denied that there was the existence of
any kind of therapeutic that would do
anything while people were dying in
droves early on especially when we
didn't really know what was going on and
you did it to get an emergency approval
it seems potentially possibly from the
fda my problem with a new drug my
problem here is with the silencing of
information of potential alternative
treatments people suppressing any
information of any potential alternative
treatments the government's saying you
are not allowed to speak about
alternative treatments the top
organizations in the world information
organizations big tech saying you're not
allowed to discuss uh any alternative
and you know it's not an alternative
treatment treatment there has been no
treatment available if you go right now
they put you on a ventilator and they
say kiss your ass goodbye which they
said yeah was worse some people have
said that now that the the the science
isn't in but there are some studies that
show maybe ventilation is worse
intubation can be worse than for example
they wanted to maybe conduct some
studies on a cpap which they thought
might be more effective i have one do
you
oh my gosh it works this sound like a
train coming through when you sleep uh
no i mean it's it's i don't
bother me
well your son's praying to god he falls
ask you or you're the roommate i know it
works anytime i fall asleep on a plane
when i wake up everyone looks at me like
i'm a dick that's also because you
ordered the fish and ate beef jerky ooh
don't sprinkle that's true you're cod
with beef jerky and i tell them there's
no cure yes
and then you smash a soft boiled egg
against the vomit value how do you like
it you like it now yeah
by the way something else is really
concerning this is something that we
discovered and again all the sources are
available lotterycrowder.com
after we covered ivermectin in great
detail on the show the journal of
antibiotics retracted an article why
on ivermectum and by the way it had
nothing to do with cohort oh we didn't
cite it as having something to do with
covet it was a an article about the
mechanism of action of ivermec which
took into account several mechanisms of
action it's anti-parasitic effect it's
protease inhibition effect in other
words we used it as a reference and it
was removed now to be clear only one
month later
they published an article on the
mechanisms of action for uh mulna
pirovir
and that was despite the authors
admitting the review article
appropriately describes the mechanism of
action of ivor mektin and none of the
authors agreed to the retraction so the
statement the reason that they retracted
this article was not because it was
incorrect it's not even because it had
anything to do with covid it's because
someone might reference it look at the
mechanism of action cross-reference it
with other recommended drugs that use a
similar mechanism of action and may
actually make an informed medical
decision between them and their
physician we can't have that so they
remove the medical information someone
argue the science the data that simply
explains the mechanism of action how
ivermectin works it's gone you can't
read up on it now despite the fact that
they admit it was correct
how is that not ball retractingly
terrifying
it is it's gonna make them a lot of
money maybe just buy their stock now i
don't know how do we get in on this game
yeah that's a good point can we buy
their stock
it's like oh geez if the game is rigged
i'd at least like to be on the winning
side you mean it's not normal for a
company to see there's nothing uh 511
can you do that are you allowed to not
say that like what you could buy stock
wise i don't know what we're allowed to
say whenever all i know is when papa
john dropped the n-bomb i bought stock
because i knew that was going to go down
eventually and sell on his apology
exactly yes well when they fired papa
john from his own company yeah i know he
brought in shaq like oh that this will
help yeah damn pop
he's like i'm not racist i like big
pizza yeah like johnny's still around
isn't he because
no problem
knock him out and i want you guys look
comment below tell me here's something
too that i wanted to just comment if you
see uh go to the sources and see we just
we put up screenshots and time machines
since the article doesn't exist anymore
yeah but you can go and read it for
yourselves and you can go back and watch
that episode we'll have a link in the
description this is something else that
i want to talk about before we go to uh
and i'll close this before we go to uh
uh mug club and play newest gender
pronouns people often [ __ ] about this
generation being soft
and i understand people say oh in my day
and every generation has said that i do
think though that this covid situation
has really shown us the issue that we
have of this generation and the issue is
is um anyone who's accomplished anything
you sort of have to determine two things
i'll use sports as an analogy here
although it can apply in life because
sports that you're actually dealing with
physical injuries so in sports you kind
of have to determine how much do you
want it and then you need to be able to
differentiate between an ouchie and an
injury right you need to say how much do
i want how much do i want to be an mvp
how much do i want to play ball in
college how much do i want to play pro
ball how much do i want to make a living
off of this and then you have to
recognize oh i tweaked my my hamstring
is a little that's a little bit stiff
that's an ouchy go out and play i blew
out my knee and i know if there's one
more play that i can't do it that's an
injury people say listen to your body
but here's the thing you can only listen
to your body when you are in tune with
your body that requires work that
requires pushing through
ouch so that you understand the
difference between it and an injury and
let's apply this to society at large
right now and i mean this it's how badly
do you want it okay how badly do you
think people right now
want to work
how badly do people want to be
productive contributing members of
society how badly you had someone like
jimmy breddick who was an old school
democrat who collected
welfare unemployment and gave it back
when he fought because he said i think
we have a country that's great enough to
help a man while he's down and i wanted
to give back to make sure that i wasn't
taking advantage nowadays
do people think how badly do you want to
live in a society where you are free how
badly do you want to earn your living
how badly do you want to be an
autonomous individual versus relying on
government at one point americans wanted
that really badly that's where they
would get on ships and travel across the
globe right where half the people didn't
make it because there were actual
outbreaks on these ships that would take
them out and then you have to recognize
the difference once you determine if you
want it or not and of course
the implication here is a lot of
americans don't want it
that's why you've rent forgiveness
that's why you had continually extended
unemployment benefits that's why you had
people saying ah 20 an hour for a job
that isn't worth it i'm not going to
apply that's why you have a labor
shortage because people don't want it
anymore people don't take pride in
accomplishments themselves and then you
look at ouchies versus injuries you know
what i would say is an injury ebola in
liberia with an almost 50 percent death
rate remember when you mocked
samaritan's purse for going in because
he didn't like the evangelical
christians who ran it
but it was a 40-something percent i'm
going by wrote here death rate in
liberia with ebola that's an injury
you could even say maybe polio or
smallpox an injury where it's anywhere
from
up to 20
of a mortality rate specifically with
children
but you do need to say how badly do i
want it and right now in this country
when we're looking at a 95 reduction in
deaths for example in a state like
florida when you're looking at a two
percent hospitalization rate
for this for the country at large all of
society and significantly lower for
people who should be taking these years
to show that they want it in the
workforce you're talking decimal
percentages of people being hospitalized
when you're talking about people in the
age of 40 we need to be clear about this
these are factual statistics is that an
ouchy or is that an injury is that worth
shutting down the entire economy is it
worth becoming like australia because
guess what there doesn't need to be any
conspiracy theory
we don't need to talk about fema camps
we don't need to talk about florida we
don't need to pull of jesse ventura look
to australia to me
that's enough and everyone out there
when you're looking at not celebrating
christmas because fauci told you so the
same guy who said you're vaccinated you
can't get it don't wear a mask we just
showed you the clip don't wear a mask if
you're vaccinated fauci said i have to
say fauci said so that we don't get
removed here that's how absurd of a
society we live in thanks to our big
tech oligarchs
when you're thinking about oh you know
what should i not do hold on a second
how badly do you want it
when people say hey
family's most important
faith family freedom guess what family
christmas thanksgiving how badly do you
want it
and is a is a fraction of a point of
being hospitalized if you're a young
person
is it an ouchie or is it an injury where
you should call off your life
and not see your family
you have to decide that everyone has to
start making these decisions i can't
make them for you i don't unlike fouchy
i don't want to make them for you and
unlike youtube i of course don't want to
make them for you so you can comment
below
and youtube you can
piss off